hello and welcome to our first Q&A first
live Q&A here at the Economist my name
is Anna bucks I'm a producer director
with the films department and we are
here to talk about Hong Kong in the
situation in Hong Kong and a lot of you
have already sent in some questions
thank you very much for that and if
you've got any questions over the next
15 minutes or so please do send them in
and I will be asking Robert guest who is
a foreign editor here at the Economist
hello Robert thank you for joining us
today my pleasure and this is a very
important topic the situation in Hong
Kong is one that the Economist has
covered a loss over the last few weeks
we've had many or a couple of front
covers on air why is it such an
important situation well there's two
reasons firstly if you have a territory
of 7.3 million people and a quarter of
them come out onto the streets yet again
over the weekend demanding some say in
how they're governed demanding not to be
put at the mercy of China's opaque and
entirely lawless judicial system partly
lawless judicial system that is that
matters these are people their rights
matter but the second reason why it's of
global consequence is because it tells
you something about China's future
relations with the outside world Hong
Kong is the gateway to China it is the
place where the majority of foreign
direct investment that goes into China
flows through Hong Kong is the place
where foreign companies that want to
have their headquarters that they want
to do business in China will place their
headquarters it's the place where
Chinese companies if they're private and
they're reputable and they they seek
global recognition they will list in
Hong Kong
rather than in the Chinese stock market
so it's absolutely crucial place the
freedoms that it has are a crucial part
of how China has managed to succeed over
the past three decades and it's facing
the question you know is China going to
snuff this out or not and I should just
point out I see that we made a thermal I
made a film last week which you can
watch if you click on me
I on the screen which is about what's at
stake for China but perhaps you could
just go into a bit more detail about the
sort of the dilemma that China is facing
what China faces a huge dilemma here on
the one hand you know the people in
charge in in Beijing or rational they
they know that if they were to send the
army in and crush the the demonstrations
in Hong Kong which they could physically
they could very easily do that you have
a very large army just parked across the
border you have a garrison already in
Hong Kong they could crush them but if
they did that they would destroy the
whole understanding the whole basis of
what's made Hong Kong so so prosperous
and important the feeling that this was
a place where you could be in China you
could be doing business with China but
you would be under different systems a
place where businesses could feel that
the rule of law replied that they
couldn't be just spirited away into some
dark secret dungeon somewhere because
they defended someone powerful within
the party now all those things would be
under threat if China were to crush this
revolt so my guess is that they're
probably not going to but at the same
time you know can they tolerate can the
authoritarian regime in China which
remember has a ruler who has pretty much
declared himself ruler for life can they
tolerate the open and mass expression of
dissent of people demanding a say in who
their rulers are that's not something
they would tolerate on the mainland so
the question is how long are they
prepared to let that last in Hong Kong
and that leads us on to our first
question and a lot of people have been
asking this and if you've got any other
questions that you want to send in
please do and what was the possibility
the protesters might lose spirits and
just sort of decide to call it a day
without any major concessions and
someone else wants to know Khan what is
the endgame here it's a similar question
okay well over the weekend we've just
had by the protestors estimates 1.7
million people came out in the rain on
the streets despite the fear of losing
their jobs despite the fear
of being shot in the eye bright the fear
of being killed that's a quarter of the
population of Hong Kong now the the
police have come up with a lower
estimate than that but there I fear
rather biased and their estimate is
massively contradicted by the the
pictures that we've seen on television
so that suggests that people are
actually passionate about this that they
really care about their future and that
they would you know they want
concessions now can they last four years
that's that's an open question we don't
know and we've got a question from Milan
Prasad who asks are the potestas
rallying behind a leader or is there any
sort of central leadership for their
sort of their struggle can you just tell
us a bit about how the protesters are
organized well there is a loose
coalition of pro-democracy groups and
NGOs sometimes helped by unions and
other groups who are calling for the
demonstrations and are being answered in
very large numbers there isn't one
leader I think if there was just one
leader that would be a very dangerous
position to have so there's a deliberate
dispersal of responsibilities because
you don't want to movement can be
decapitated by removing one person I
mean I'm interested you've covered a lot
of Patera tests over your many years
working journalism how does the Hong
Kong protest compared to other process
that you've covered and do you think
that ultimately they will achieve what
they want well it's a very large protest
to begin with very few places I can
think of in the world where you can get
those kinds of crowds on the street it's
it's been mostly people it hasn't been
entirely peaceful obviously you know the
police have a shot you know beanbag
pellets into people's eyes and have been
some demonstrators including over the
weekend which was mostly peaceful there
were some demonstrators who threw eggs
at a police station and overturned some
rubbish bins but by the standards of
protests this big it has been very
peaceful and it's essential that it
remains so because
if the protesters start you know killing
or injuring people that will give the
authorities a pretext to crack down very
hard indeed the thing that is difficult
it is it is always much easier for a
non-violent protest movement to succeed
if the people they're protesting against
have some conscience so you know
demonstrations against Saddam Hussein
never worked because he just killed
everybody demonstrations again you know
Gandhi's demonstrations against the
British in India ultimately prevailed
because you know with some exceptions
the you know the ruling power was not
prepared to use massive lethal force on
an entire country that big so you know
those those things tend to win with
China it's very hard to say I mean you
know they don't want to have lots of
people dead in the streets but they have
in the past demonstrated a willingness
to do that now in the channel Minh
Square massacre thirty years ago that
was you know that was hotly debated
within the Chinese leadership there were
those who said no we should just let the
demonstrations continue they will burn
themselves out eventually and there were
those who said no we cannot tolerate any
public affront to the authority of the
Communist Party to rule forever without
reference to voters and let's shoot them
now and that was the rule that prevailed
my suspicion is that the Chinese army is
more restrained and more professional
now than it was thirty years ago and
that the leadership is more attuned to
just what a disaster it would be if they
put the army onto the streets of Hong
Kong and started killing people
but you can never rule anything out I
mean a lot of a lot of the comments that
we've had have been about international
response and a lot of people have
mentioned the fact that Hong Kong was a
British colony and have asked will the
UK intervene you know what what is
British responsibility here well I mean
you can argue that Britain has a
historic responsibility but I don't
think it has any power to intervene I
mean British government could make a
statement
I don't know saying
possibly the Chinese government was not
adhering to all the agreements that were
made at the time of the handover in the
1990s but it doesn't realistically have
any any leverage to make the Chinese
government do anything other than what
the Chinese government wants to do this
is this is a crisis that will be
resolved based on the decisions of the
Chinese government and the people of
Hong Kong we just had a comment let's
just come in that says um do you foresee
the u.s. getting more involved in this
affair no I mean it was very clear that
Donald Trump is not interested he has in
fact quite wrongly characterized the
movement as being a riot he's not paying
attention to the details he's interested
in his trade dispute with China which he
views purely through the lens of what's
happening to American manufacturing so
no I don't think that the Americans are
going to get involved now interestingly
within China within the Chinese media
there's this ridiculous conspiracy
theory that is being put out that this
is entirely cooked up by the West that
this is not a spontaneous display by
Hong Kong as of dissatisfaction with the
authoritarian Big Brother next door but
something that has been fermented and
orchestrated by foreign forces meaning
the Americans that's ridiculous I mean
personally they have no reason to want
to do that and secondly they have no
capacity to do that the idea that the
CIA could get two million people onto
the streets of Hong Kong is ridiculous
the frightening thing is as our Jaguar
columnist pointed out recently quite a
lot of people within the Chinese
government appear to believe this and
that's worrying and if you want to read
that you can click on the I now and I
should hopefully give you the link to
that article on The Economist website
and if it's surrett if the UK isn't
gonna do anything in America is not
going to do anything you know if you're
a Hong Kong protester right now who do
you ask for help from who can help you
we know any organization in which card
the countries
is going to come to their aid well no
one I mean they they they need to stick
together they need to stand firm and
they need to be aware that although the
the Chinese government has most of the
power it doesn't hold all of the cards
by being out on the streets and asking
for things they create a set of
incentives whereby it's very much in the
interest of the Chinese government to be
patient to wait to possibly make some
concessions and to hope for this to you
know eventually get quieter but it's not
that Outsiders are going to come to the
rescue of Hong Kongers it's that Hong
Kong is by boldly expressing their
desire for the freedoms that they were
promised may prevail a lot of our
commentators our commenters have been
asking about I've been asking about
Taiwan and they've been asking about
Macau could you just talk a little bit
about how this the situation in Hong
Kong might affect Taiwan is the really
important one so the Chinese government
one of their most important stated goals
is the reunification of Taiwan with the
motherland now the way things stand at
the moment where Taiwan is a rich
democracy and China is a dictatorship
there's no way that that's going to
happen voluntarily people don't can't
get sort of you know 20 million people
and make them voluntarily give up the
right to vote voluntarily give up the
freedom that they currently enjoy from
being arrested in the middle of the
night by an unaccountable States nobody
surrenders that voluntarily the only way
that in the relatively short term you
could imagine a voluntary reunification
ie a reunification without a war would
be if the Hong Kong one country two
systems' idea were seem to be working if
it was seen to be the case that Hong
Kong
having been promised a continuation of
the rule of law and civil liberties for
50 years after the handover if that was
really respected by China so this is
this is the other really big reason why
it would be disastrous from China's
perspective from the perspective of the
Chinese Communist Party to crush the
demonstrations in Hong Kong is that
would make it absolutely impossible to
get a voluntary reunification with
Taiwan and of course a war would be
catastrophic and just to ask you about
Macau we've got a question here from
Wendland SEMA and Macau is another
former colony why does it remain largely
quiet compared to Hong Kong it's much
smaller yes it's not a place I mean Hong
Kong has a sort of vibrant dynamic
mobile outward-facing economy with lots
of people passing through and lots of a
broad understanding among the population
of the benefits of dealing with the
outside world and of the rule of law
Macau is is a special place you know
they they have casinos there but it's
nowhere near as as it's nowhere near as
sophisticated as the places of Hong Kong
but I think we should leave it here
there thank you very much Robert and
thank you for joining me thank you so
much to all your questions as well and
this is the first in a series of live
YouTube Q&A that when we're running if
you click on the bell then you can
subscribe and you will be able to let
you know when the next one is coming up
and that's going to be your own
reforestation and climate change we'll
be asking countries save the planet if
you want to read more about what The
Economist has written on Hong Kong and
the situation there you could go to the
Economist website economists calm and
you can subscribe you can either
subscribe to the paper or get a digital
subscription and I'm stay tuned for more
of these Q&A thank you so much for
watching thank you
you